let's say that you have decided to go
canoeing and right over here this is a
top view of our river right here
this is our river and let's say that the
current the river is going towards the
right
so there's two different directions
so there's two different directions that
you could be canoeing in you could
imagine someone who is canoeing in the
same direction as the current so they
are canoeing that way and then you could
imagine another person who's canoeing
the other way
so someone who's canoeing upstream this
person is canoeing downstream this
person is canoeing upstream so they are
going in that direction
so pause this video and think about
which person is going to have to expend
more energy or which person is going to
have to be more active and which person
is going to be more passive
well yes this wasn't an incredibly hard
question if you are going with the flow
of current as the person in yellow is
here they don't even have to take their
paddles out they can just take a nap and
the boat will naturally go with the
current they would be
they could be just moving passively
while the person in blue here they're
going to have to work really really
really hard they're going to have to
paddle some just to not even move to the
right and then even paddle even more to
actually go against the current so this
person would have to be very active
and so this is really just a metaphor
for what we're going to talk about now
and that's the idea in biology of active
versus passive transport so let's start
with maybe the the more pleasant one in
either situation and that is passive
transport
so passive transport is when something
goes with the gradient so what do i mean
by that so you could have a
concentration gradient
so let's say that on let's say i have a
tube of some kind
and let's say it's it's filled with
water and dissolved in that water at
this end of the tube i have a high
concentration of some
molecule or something right over here
while on the right hand side i have a
low concentration so what do we think is
going to happen
well these things are just going to
naturally move around and over time
they're going to bounce their way so
that after a little bit of time has
passed a lot of these things are just
going to passively move to the right
and so at some point you might have an
equal concentration or roughly equal
throughout this entire container and so
this movement along your concentration
gradient here you're moving from high
concentration to low concentration this
would be passive transport
this is a concentration gradient that
we're moving along let me write that
down
this is our concentration gradient but
you could also have an electrical
gradient
so
let's take a similar type of container
maybe it's filled with water and on the
left hand side imagine if you have a
bunch of
positive particles or molecules and on
the right you have a bunch of negative
particles or molecules
well the positive ones repel each other
so do the negative ones but they attract
the positives attract the negative and
the negative attract the positive and so
you would think that things would
naturally move down their electrical
gradient the positives want to go away
from each other and they are drawn to
the negative similarly the negatives
want to get away from each other and
they are drawn to the positive so
whether you're talking about a
concentration gradient or an electrical
gradient and sometimes you have a
combination of both an electrochemical
gradient when you're moving along with
your gradient you don't have to use any
energy that's known as passive transport
so no
no
energy energy need needed
it's just going to happen naturally
now the opposite is the notion of active
transport
active
transport and this is when you go
against the gradient so an active
transport would be somehow let's say
you're in this situation right over here
somehow getting one of these particles
let me do in that same color somehow
getting one of these particles instead
of moving to go in that direction it
will actually go against its gradient in
that direction or another situation is
imagine if you have a positive particle
right over here instead of making it
instead of it naturally just going to
that direction somehow you make it go
against its gradient and you make it go
closer to the other positive particles
well this is going to require energy
to do
and probably the most cited example or
the most common example that we're going
to see in biology class of active
transport is what's known as a sodium
potassium pump which we will study in
detail in other videos but let's say
that this thing that i'm drawing here in
white this is a cell
membrane
and i'm drawing these gaps for a reason
and
what you have on the outside of the cell
membrane you have
some potassium ions
on the outside but you have a lot more
on the inside so these are all potassium
ions on the inside of your cell and then
so let me just write k plus k plus k
plus k plus k plus
and you'll have some sodium ions on the
inside of your cell
and a plus but you have a lot more on
the outside of your cell and in general
the outside of your cell is going to
have many more positive ions than the
inside
maybe you already see where
this is going
and a plus
and a plus and a plus i think you get
the idea and a plus
and a plus
now if on this membrane let's ignore
this part right over here if i just had
a channel right over here that was open
only to potassium so only potassium can
go through
so
only
potassium can go through
this channel right over here what do you
think is going to happen well you would
have passive transport these positively
charged potassiums right over here they
would go down their concentration
gradient there's more likely to have a
potassium ion just bump in the right way
just right over here so that goes
through the channel because there's just
more potassiums out on on the inside of
the cell than there would be on the
outside and so this this potassium is
going down their concentration gradient
from high concentration to low
concentration through this channel this
would be passive transport
passive
transport
but you could imagine there's also
active transport
and that active transport is what pumps
the sodium ions inside the cell outside
of the cell even though it's not only
against its concentration gradient it's
also against its electrical gradient the
outside's more positive so you wouldn't
think a positive ion would naturally go
outside and the outside has more sodium
than it does inside but the sodium
potassium pump still pumps those sodiums
outside
and as i hint it at it does this using
energy so you'll sometimes see a sodium
potassium pump drawn like this
and once again i'm not going to go into
depth on
it we have a whole video on it but the
general idea is is that the sodiums bind
over here and then some atp which is the
powerhouse of cells which we will study
in more depth later on in biology it
leverages its energy to change the shape
of the proteins that make up the sodium
potassium pump to then pump these
sodiums outside of the cell so it's
going to go from this shape and then
it's just going to you could view it as
opening it up that way the real
enzymes look quite different but that's
the general idea you use energy in the
form of atp
to pump the sodiums out against both
their concentration gradient and their
electrical gradient and that's why it's
called active transport